lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hablar de las tablas de valor posicional
también conocidas como gráficos de valor
posicional ya hemos hablado del valor
posicional en vídeos anteriores y las
tablas o gráficos de valor posicional
son una forma muy clara de conocer cuál
es el valor que tenemos en cada posición
aquí nos piden usar la tabla de valor
posicional para escribir 60 mil 229 este
es el gráfico o tabla de valor
posicional y nos dicen escribe cada
dígito en el espacio correspondiente de
la tabla de valor posicional en realidad
lo que nos preguntan es cuántas decenas
de millar tenemos cuantos millares
cuántas centenas cuántas decenas y
cuántas unidades y como siempre es muy
buena ideal que ustedes traten de
resolver esto antes de que yo lo
resuelva hagan esto pausa en el vídeo y
en un pedazo de papel traten de
identificar cuántas decenas de millar
hay en 60.200 29 cuantos millares
cuántas centenas cuántas decenas y
cuántas unidades hay
vamos a resolverlo juntos podemos
comenzar por la izquierda en las decenas
de millar esta es la posición de las
unidades esta es la posición de las
decenas está es la de las centenas ésta
es la de los millares y esta es la de
las decenas de millar podemos observar
que hay seis decenas de millar y todo lo
que tenemos que hacer es escribir un 6
en este espacio seis decenas de millar
cuantos millares hay estos están un
lugar a la derecha esto es interesante
podemos ver claramente que hay cero
millares escribimos cero millares
ustedes pueden decir que al leer el
número decimos sesenta mil 229 acaso no
son sesenta millares pues así es pero
esos ya los tomamos en cuenta en las
seis decenas de millar pero en la
posición de los millares
no tenemos alguno no nos movemos a la
posición de las centenas y vemos
claramente que hay dos centenas luego
pasamos a la posición de las decenas en
hay dos escenas y por último pero no
menos importante en la posición de las
unidades
tenemos 99 unidades y terminamos el
objetivo de este vídeo es que se
familiaricen con este tipo de formato de
las tablas y gráficos de valor
posicional ya que es una manera muy
clara de escribir cuánto valor tenemos
en cada posición en un número como este
con esto terminamos